Your generation has been condemned to
never having the solace
that your parents generation had.
That even if they went through,
about unemployment,
about the bankruptcy,
that lost their house,
or at least they could hope that
within a reasonable frame of time,
their kids, you,
their grandkids
would have a better life than they did.
That's no longer the case.
Because capitalism,
in my view, in 2,008
met a crisis that, uh,
effectively killed it.
In the same way that 1991
was the crisis that killed socialism and communism
and social democracy.
The great defeat of the Left,
2008 was a great defeat of capitalism.
But because we of the left were incapable, uh, of, uh,
presenting your generation with an, a viable,
credible alternative,
the result is, um.
Remember what Rosario Luxembourg once said or asked,
socialism or barbarism?
Well, it's barbarism
with, uh, you know,
the bankers acquiring power that they never had before.
And now we have big tech,
what I called cloud capital, which, um,
it's creating a new kind of feudalism.
But this is not even capitalism anymore.
So I think that this is what your generation
is experiencing.
And my generation,
we are responsible for it.